stephane mostly talking about the
weather so a very very English topic
thank you very much
excuse at the beginning because it's a
very big topic there's a lot to talk and
I'm just skipping over I hope I have
provided a lot of links in the
presentation which you can later use if
you want to go a bit more deeper in any
topic I have also a colleague to be with
me today if you later want to have some
question or discuss with anything we're
here to stay shortly after the meeting
to discuss something so let's get
started quickly about May I'm the head
of the developing section at ECMWF which
I will explain in a second I call myself
veteran a sufferer developed because I'm
quite long in the business and done
graphics when SGI was still doing
graphics and now getting more mode to
use open source environment and things
but as you can see from my name's i'm
not very creative when it comes to if
you come up with my name so they get up
in twitter more importantly we're a
development section of over 20
developers now ECMWF c++ spice and a lot
web development databases of course
storing data there's a lot of
developments going on for us is a lot
about software packages we provide not
just for ourselves but for the community
around the world the methodological
community so it's a it's a very big job
for us to do their stuff in a lot of
different formats and the time
criticality of
for weather is very important so that's
a big driver for our developments but I
mentioned ECMWF what is it
ECMWF stands for European Centre for
medium-range weather forecast very short
brief name we are an intergovernmental
organization so even some of Europe in
the name we like the european space
agency we are intergovernmental so we're
not part of the European Union we do a
lot of work with the European Union as
you will see from my presentation but
we're not actually part of it so we're
not directly affected at the moment by
things going on let's say it's very
indirectly affair but we have 22 member
states about Europe 12 cooperative
states and if you look at the map you
realize there are some countries which
are member states which are not in the
European Union so we're a bit wider than
that
we are mainly located headquarter wise
in Redding UK we're starting since
December months ago we started building
a new data center in Bologna Italy that
is where in future our supercomputer
will go but the headquarter will stay in
Redding west of London here we are now
roughly 350 staff located all in reading
at the moment so what we do is mainly is
a 24/7 operational aspect of weather
forecasting and that means delivering
the forecast time critically to all our
users customers which are mostly initial
weather services but also were the
business agencies businesses this means
in practice terabytes of data being
delivered very quickly within minutes
around the world we operating to do that
HP seed it supercomputer center with two
supercomputers which as I mentioned we
will move to Bologna in 2020 and we're
also operating the biggest archived on
our enmity logical data with 250
petabytes very similar with so you might
guess now what we're doing from the name
Europe I explained weather forecast but
you might wonder what is medium-range a
medium-range many mistake for being the
distance but it's actually time and it's
defined as 3 to 15 days in metrology and
perhaps to explain why we're doing it
and why it's so special for us is is you
go back to the 60s when the first idea
came to create the center is in the 60s
and beginning 70s weather forecasting
progress to do focus beyond 2 days but
if you want to do any forecast beyond 3
days as you can see from the weather
system which is there on flora Florida
in within 4 days
it hits UK so if you want to do a
forecast in four days for the UK you
need you need to know what's up in the
US so to do anything you need a global
forecast and global forecasts are highly
expensive to run you need a super super
computer infrastructure it's a lot of
data involve data moving and it would be
very expensive if every weather service
would do it around the world so in the
60s the member states are shown before
came together saying let's
put this effort together because a
global focus will be for everybody the
same and that is exactly what the center
does we provide this focus beyond three
days so if you see anywhere around the
world to focus beyond three days it's
very likely that the forecasters will
have looked at our forecast so that is
something which there are other medium
range forecasts but forecasters around
the world always take different models
into account and we are definitely one
of the one that we'll look at so what
does ECM that we have provided as at
Cisco as I said operation focus I
mentioned the medium range but this
medium range as I said in the 70s we
started to look three four days now
we're actually already running monthly
and seasonal forecasting and as you can
imagine when you go and these kind of
time ranges a the forecast there will be
lots of uncertainty so what we do
actually we don't run one model
we're running 52 models we run one in
high resolution one with the best
starting conditions and then 50 forecast
which in a lower resolution get slightly
tempted slightly changed a starting
condition and that will give us
statistically information about the
credibility of the forecast so if you
would run if one single forecast you
will run after lately after a week the
uncertainty of that would quite go down
but but looking at the spread of
forecast
and here you can see it's plotted on the
right side the 52 different forecasts
you can get information which you then
can use statistically to analyze a
certainty of a forecast and then you
have products like on the left side
which gives them the uncertainty and you
can see the bars of uncertainty over the
time so in very simple terms that is
very much simplified how our system
works is you get lots and lots of in
millions tens of millions of
observations in which have to be of
course data quality needs to be done the
maps we validated all these observations
and got effete into the model which we
call the integrated forecast system
which analyzed the data does a good
starting condition for the model
then runs the model which has different
components which I don't go in here at
the moment in this talk but different
things and then produced the model
outputs which we then what we call here
the product generation is a time
critical delivery to all our users and
there's also Web Services because as
also forecasters want to look at past
forecasts want to study in detail at the
parameters of the focus that they can do
through the web services so that's a
chance and as mentioned already we are
operating very large archive a data
coming in model output is all stored
there and in the model to do it all we
run supercomputers as I said we run two
supercomputers one research one
operations and it gives us also a
fallback in case something happened to
the operation machine we can kick off
the research working you set machine for
operations and quick words about what
comes in as I said is it's tens of
millions of observations coming in
mainly to nowadays is satellite data
there is and it might look like
satellite is now what is driving it
definitely improves the quality of the
forecast but the other observations are
very important as a reference also to
calibrate satellite so that is still
important to keep in our ended why we're
generating this plot is because we have
also a monitoring function we're giving
feedback to satellite providers to the
different agencies who collect the
weather information to say something is
possibly going wrong or the data is
biased so this means we have a lot of
statistical analysis and graphical
analysis of what we are getting in this
information to give feedback on that a
word about the model output we're
generating it's all most of the layers
of the model actually aren't Erika
harmonics representation something you
will not want to use in day to day work
and then we have also something called
Gaussian a grids on which model are I
worked on and this is it's very
carefully consideration when you look at
at output because if you look you might
be familiar with satellite
where you have pixels for which a value
is for an area but for a model it's
about grid points so the the value get
from the model is only valid at this
grid point if you want to have any make
any assumption or any analysis about any
point between grid points you need to
interpolate you cannot just do a simple
assumption that this point is nearest
time so that's that's very important
differences to what you would see with
satellite and but very few users work
with these raw data that normally get it
already interpolated but it's part of
these product generation software we run
that we also in real time generate it in
grits how users use it and then even
then users that do mostly two things
either do the products I show here on
the on the Left where they do take their
as I said these 52 forecast do
statistical analysis this for example is
a map a popular forecasters it shows
anomaly anomalies so where will it be
colder than usual where will it be
hotter where will it be more wet than
usual more dry more windy so that gives
some guidance to see which in the next
two weeks possibly there will be changes
to the weather and where they then will
keep an eye on and then on the other
side that's see on the right side is
another important way how users look at
our data they'd settle for a location I
don't think it's reading here and then
they will have a time series of the data
of the 15 days or 10 days depending how
long the one to look at and then they
see how the parameters are looking at
will develop over time and as you can
see in the middle one quite nicely the
uncertainty over time is increasing so
that is what you expect with a further
forecasts it would be weird if it would
be get but it gives weather situation
where they actually the certainty can be
better in a second week than in some
days of the first day is kind of quick
thing about the data I mentioned already
and we're getting we preparing ourselves
at the moment for a big increase of data
a factor of five at least coming in
because we know there's a lot of more
satellite data coming in and also our
way getting more data in we are better
now to analyze
data coming in and allow more data in
because we're now much better in
accepting data if there's some
uncertainty with them because our
algorithm take part of it so that is
definitely increasing but the big
increase comes the fact that 1000 in
decrease of models the center it's it's
not long ago that they grits 100
kilometers and we're now talking about
less than 5 kilometers great on global
scale and that's that is showing then in
the in the in the data amounts we will
have but I mean this is now all this is
purely what I said about the weather
forecast we're doing the media in the
medium range these kind of data but
ECMWF and this is its number for weather
forecasting there's a lot of other
activities which follow up from weather
forecasts where the focuses of them the
beginning of a chain to use other
products and here's a we have a big
cooperation with the European Commission
you might have heard about the European
Copernicus program is a massive big
program by the European Commission to
make science and earth observations data
much more easily available for a private
citizen but also industry and we are
part of that one it's six services that
I've mentioned above atmosphere
Marineland climate change security
emergency on behalf of the Commission we
are operating the atmosphere and the
climate change and we're very heavily
involved in emergency because flood
forecasting and fire forecasting we do a
lot the forest fire forecasting we do a
lot any similar bear so we are heavily
involved with this one so we'd play a
big part of this one it's one about your
Commission and just to mention the
atmospheric service monitoring service
is very interesting if you want to build
I want to look at data like air
pollution chemicals in the in the
atmosphere sand and dust which in some
areas have a big impact on for some
flight routing and things of that so and
there's an example here the column of
sulfur dioxide and the atmosphere so
it's very interesting to to
check on quality air pollution and
quality all the data from the camps is
free and accessible for for anybody to
build products on and the Commission is
very keen of users using this so there's
a lot of activity so have if you're
interested in that go to the data to the
link I put there to the data of the
service and then the other service I
mentioned it's a climate change service
and this is mainly reanalysis data the
seasonal forecast I mentioned and also
climate scenarios which not so many atom
at ECMWF but we say we connect them to
the service and the c.d.s the climate
data store is is the way how its
presented is the portal on its own and
it's very interesting why I'm mentioning
it is because a lot of these datasets
are too large the reanalysis data set
which is very very popular for a lot of
industries because it contains for the
last the weather of the last decades so
it's a record of the last decades of
weather very interesting for industry a
lot of products are built on top of it
but the data set is I think is now going
beyond 5 petabytes so it's not something
you just download and work on so what
exit the data it offers data download
but what it also offers is actually an
interface which allows you to access the
data through pison at on the server side
and it's all started last year so if you
want to have a go at it we're really
looking for a feedback but this is
really a new step for us to let users on
our side do products and what you do is
this perhaps a bitter shot you're
writing your Python script so you can
you have seen with the decorators I hope
you see better than I can from here and
you define the decorators your interface
which parameters you want the users to
choose and then you generate a graph or
you can generate a product but graph
equivalency easier so here I plot for
the last 7 no 8 years the 2 meter
temperature so the ground temperature at
London so you can see the seasonal
variation and also the variation over
the day making the line very thick and
so you can do apps you can develop
little applications
on this portal and the next step will be
to have a little app store where you
then can share these kind of apps and
make them available but at the moment
you can see you have the code and you
have your own area where you can do your
own little scripts and stuff so if
you're interested in any of these
datasets this is something you can play
with without having much to invest on
your on your site so now I'm starting a
little bit more talking about the Python
what we use it for at ECMWF we build a
lot of systems we have a service for
forecasters which around the world can
look at our focus so they don't need to
get all the data they can look often
that they cannot even get all the data
because it's not physically not possible
so this web browser is called ec charts
allows them to see this data and there's
a web interface where they can
interactively go select different
parameters look at Hurricane
developments I don't go into detail this
one here because we presented actually a
colleague of us three years ago he
presented at here but another thing we
do is we talked about downloading data
which you can go by going to the web
page select the data set and then click
it out but you can also do it through
batch which you might want to do because
otherwise you get a strain on your
fingers clicking all the data you want
and we allow it through pies in the
price and interface we have and there's
information for the ischium that we've
data how to get and the Copernicus data
and you can install these API through pi
PI I only put the links here because
there's information on how you can set
it up because you needed to access token
you have to accept that you that you're
the licensed condition which is free but
you have still to accept that before you
can have access another thing we use a
pison is we have massive big sweets
sweets are defining the workflow we have
at ECMWF data coming in as soon data is
processed feed it into the model have
the model the different parts of the
model running then do the post
processing archive in the data all this
has to be expressed and it has to be
done of course in a way that it has
dependence
these assumed this job finishes start
the other job make sure that money
operators we are 24/7 so we have always
stopped working around the clock they
can immediately see if something gets
delayed is something so we have a
workflow manager called easy flow and
their this is the user interface you can
see on the right side how the operator
and analyst a forecast a researcher can
see how the jobs are doing but to define
these weights we use pison have defined
the Python interface for users to define
how the jobs are what has to run and how
it gets scheduled between the different
machines because some workflow start on
a supercomputer and then go on
processing machine so it also goes
beyond a across machines so in that
shows a bit of a build system we
schedule organize our work with pison so
what's about the number crunching and
for a long time we have a lot of number
to crunch where time critical so we we
have to do it also in the HPC but for a
long time we did not look at pricing we
traditionally use a lot of Fortran we
still in the model are mostly Fortran
and we have now for post-processing and
most services moved C C++ but we're now
have now started looking more and more
in pison and it definitely would say
that the interest the the environment
and the price and definitely has
improved of what we have seen in recent
years are very happy with that and I
think you will find there's a lot of num
focus logos which we're making use of so
we use it a lot now for the
post-processing validation verification
of of the forecast but the the real
challenge is for us what they have not
talked about and I don't want to talk
about it we have quite a lot of
different formats which are not publicly
used formats are very specific to
metrology very optimized for what we're
doing and to get them all in these
standard tools that is not very easy and
that is often the challenge to make use
of you see there's a good tool but how
do we get our data and that's a very big
challenge and also for users we don't we
don't want users having to understand
how our data is organized because that
is not the main problem they want to
extract eight are the one to subset data
and get the data they want so we
trying to abstract it in data cube so
that users have a way to access the data
without learning something very specific
to metrology and what we found very
interesting what we started using since
two years now is X array which is you
can say more multi-dimensional pandas
and it has really proven to be very good
for us especially for the user side how
to ease more easily access our data but
this is structures very much oriented to
netcdf a format used in metrology but
not much in operation metrology so what
we did I think there was a big step for
us we went to the community we invited
we had to PI some workshops were invited
they keep people from these packages to
ECMWF discuss with them how we can
improve this situation because there's
really a lot of good developments out
there which we want to make use of it's
only that we need to make it all so easy
to get our data in and we learnt a lot
about we especially we call now a new PI
Center faces more the second-generation
pison interface it's the first
generation we started off with 15 years
ago there were just the same Fortran and
C interfaces we just transferred them
into Python so you your Python program
looked like your Fortran program just
Python syntax so you don't really gain
much out of it you just can say you do
it in Python in worst case you've got it
often slower than also because you did
not make use of anything from someplace
and so there was a report lesson also to
to go out to the community and really
learn what we're doing and one thing
we're really interesting is is
developing like dusk the the distributed
about processing of data and we were
lucky that we had actually very good
session at our last workshop at ECMWF
last year that we could have a good
session about it but very good talks and
discussions because it was a real
workshop we also should get back to the
bit we not just sit and listen like here
we had also roundtable and had how we
can proceed and how we can do it for our
community and as a better services - it
was not just us so we are really
interested to look at that there's
something we're now exploring how we can
do much more
tribute processing with tasks on our
data and just nice short URL in the
bottom if you want to have a look we
recorded all the presentations so if you
want to have to see what we've done
please follow the link I hope there will
be a PDF where you then can click on the
links under ok I said now how we get our
data and so there was X array a very
nice package it's done by the community
and how we can make use of it so we're
very proud that we hope did the right
thing of talking to the community and we
actually managed we have a format called
grip which it's very specific to
metrology not much known outside
metrology and we work together with the
community and a company called P open in
Italy how we could implement it and now
X array with an extension can now read
the group data directly in and that
means as a user you you only would work
with X array and if you extra I used
before you don't need to learn anything
new to work with our data because you
can use well what you have done before
and the only thing is if you you you say
when you know when you no no no I'm
going to if you if you load the grip
file you say engine CF grip and then it
knows that it has to go and get the CF
grip and lots and then reads it
so it's hopefully for the users the
easiest way to work with it and after
that it's a data array ok I got to sign
that my time is running out just to
mention historically for 30 years we we
have also provided a graphics package to
do weather maps
it's very data aware from the
metrological point of view so the users
has a very high level package to do
visualization maps it's also now
pythonic and has been can be used within
jupiter notebooks and but what i would
like to say is all these different
packages we have the decoders the
visualization the interpolation I did
not mention but they're all coming
together in what we call met View met
use our workstation patched system we
have at ECMWF it had his own macro
language which was already very
very close to pison it was only close it
had not the module import and everything
but the syntax was very similar so what
we did now is we actually made it a
pison so you can actually also write the
batch script in jupiter notebooks and
it's very helpful for all our users who
use our workstation because what they
actually do is as analyst who do quickly
generate batch jobs they're actually
generating so that they're setting up
their plot setting colors and then what
they do is they open let's say an empty
pison script and they're drag and drop
this icon in and it generates the code
for them so whatever they have to find
where the 2 meter information comes from
it's the they don't need to worry how
the code is so just drag and drop and
generating this code and then they can
just say visualize and then I can see
the data and that we have now
transferred all to pice and so that they
can be used from Python very quick word
we are that is new for us a year ago
that would have been empty slide and
we're now getting out github pipe I
condor we have a docker hub image we
really try to be there and as I said we
also tried to have tools which users can
easily use so how you can say I mention
already docker hub we have a docker hub
image if you want to play our software
around have a look at that it's install
our software or the pison interfaces and
there is also a lots of jupiter
notebooks which you can see what we are
doing and how you could work with our
data yes quickly
I guess that is definitely the imports
like I also pitch a little bit here now
for us and we have job offerings at the
moment but also in general I think quite
interesting one as I said we're pushing
quite a limit of data and systems we
very much high performance computing web
developments we're really having very
interesting tasks so if you're
interested in that have a look at our
web page what we also outsourcing and
tendering out a lot of our developing
work so if you have a little company or
your consultant you might want to have
it look at this page and we're looking
generally for help and can look for
contractors or for example in specific
areas like
porting IDL code into pison it seems to
be something quite a lot of people do
because we realize this we're not not
the first one doing it and and otherwise
as I said we're now getting to get up I
mean we are also wanting we had already
always contribution with other Weather
Service's stuff regarding our software
now we want to put it out and really
more visible like the CF grip I
mentioned this is all out was and please
have a look if you want to contribute to
our I'm so suffer because we're
definitely open for that and last but
not least we're also doing a sum of
weather code we started that last year
so M we will unfortunately slightly too
early because I have not published it on
the 21st of January we will publish our
challenges so we had Eason berry have
looked around what kind of challenges
talked to our users what were little
tasks which would not manage to do and
where we can need help of the community
and then we will select if you can apply
for if you think you can do something
right a little proposal and then we
select five proposal for over the summer
with a little bit of pocket money we
work on these problems and there will be
some pythonic one there will be one
definitely but one visualization one I
have to mention that so have a look at
that and see if that might be of
interest for you and that is I would
have to say four things
[Applause]